it's her body though you did it okay so
there have been reports that Mike Tyson
is willing to pay someone and it doesn't
specify whether it's a man or a woman
but some 110 million dollar ten million
dollars to marry his eldest daughter
Mike eat I see I see I think I heard
that's fake but I heard that like that
got around and then I this is the
Michael Blackson thing yes then Michael
blacks is the one who like breath go
ahead but the comedian Michael black you
know that is not solaris but so you see
that obviously she's a full-figured
woman yes plus plus a carry-on wool know
is that his wife is that my wife that's
who's with right now I'm not sure if
he's married but they're together yeah
the whole story is that he is trying to
help his daughter look for love right
now
there was something with Michael
Blackson we don't have the mighty blacks
earthy something there's like a little
bit about oh my god go to that's the
story he's a funny I go black market
joke Ison went at him because he wrote a
letter to he wrote a DM DM Mike Tyson
I'm a knock a black coffee
we go to this gym this is the best this
is the best part of the [ __ ] story so
he DM sir
do they have where it's at if this is
true I think I finally later settle down
oh no you got it you gotta find good
timing Michael Blackson DM to Michael
Michael that's so great look it just
said it because listen you black [ __ ]
no no no no no that's the response you
got to get Mike relaxin ceases DMS the
real Mike Tyson you can say I'll marry
your daughter and Mike goes that it's a
funny DM but I don't what the [ __ ] he's
thinking oh here it is
so you know this is Michael Blackson
taught D I mean Mike Tyson out 10
million agios if this is true I think
I'm ready I'm ready to settle down I
know I've been dipping and dabbing a few
snow bunnies in Asian persuasion but I'm
ready for your beautiful Queen I'm ready
to give you some grandkids that will
have the complexion of Tyson Bedford
knowledge of Cicely Tyson talk to you
like Mike Tyson hopefully not built like
Tyson Fury I really don't give a [ __ ]
about the money I'll take it waiting to
hear from your father-in-law sir
so that Mike Tyson sees it goes it's
listen you black a little [ __ ] listen
you black little [ __ ] this [ __ ] ain't
real and soon as I find the person to
meme I'm gonna knock him the [ __ ] out so
make sure it ain't you burnt roach
licking [ __ ]
my daughter's happily parts my
daughter's happily in a relationship
with a nice-looking man so she's not
interested in an overcooked hot dog like
you
next time you do my podcast i'ma knock
the black off mode it might take a year
because you black as [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of my DM before I get your black ass
too poor you know yeah you know that huh
no oh my god so he hit me the Alfred
Tamila to get his daughters just it's
just fake it's just rolling and then
Michael Blackson saw that and DM the
real Mike Tyson that's unlike this wants
to fight a lot but I like Michael
Michael Blackson response oh my god what
the [ __ ] am i sorry please don't hit me
I'm just a beach beach ass that that's
from that's from Friday oh you played a
character on Friday huh fine
you didn't think you was great spawn
back I feel like that's a lot of people
they don't like you there Sean make fun
of people and then they don't realize
that they actually see that oh [ __ ] Mike
Tyson just got Street could he not could
do you think he can knock out house
maybe less white I'm straight as
father's right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]